[Aplausos]
no les ha pasado que a veces se
despiertan con una sensación extraña y
deciden que para solucionarlo hay que
acudir al librero más cercano sacar un
texto abrir las páginas pasar las hojas
y leer te es saberse vivo todavía
eso no pasa por lo menos no hay
evidencia que compruebe que
fisiológicamente el ser humano tiene una
necesidad poética
sin embargo creo y considero que si
tenemos una necesidad social política y
cultural de la palabra poética
hace algunos años acudí a una asesoría y
le pregunté al profesor que qué era lo
que podía hacer para mejorar en su
materia él me dijo bueno es que tu
problema es que lees mucho y que lo que
lees es poesía yo te recomendaría que
dejaras de leerlo de todas formas no te
sirve para nada no la necesitas en ese
momento me di cuenta de dos cosas la
primera poco sabía el del impacto
positivo que puede tener la poesía en
nosotros como individuos y como
comunidad
la segunda que iba a dedicar mi vida a
la creación difusión y reivindicación de
la poesía
pero que es poesía de acuerdo con
jacques derrida para entender el
significado de un concepto no hay que
acudir a los diccionarios sino a los
hablantes
de acuerdo con luz a alvarado la poesía
es un espacio en la periferia que nos
permite ver todo de manera mucho más
amplia margie saber dice que la poesía
no es paralela a los sistemáticos no
responde a lo canónico la poesía es
revolucionaria araceli mancilla nos
comparte que la poesía nos permite a los
lectores ya los escritores ser parte de
un proceso de revelación a veces nos
remonta al origen y a veces nos señala
el porvenir
héctor artigas comenta que la poesía es
sinónimo de libertad
martín tonal mayor que la poesía
construye puentes y josé manuel suárez
noriega que la poesía es un diálogo que
se construye entre distintas voces
entonces en termino de esta conversación
que ustedes y yo estamos construyendo en
este momento la poesía va a ser eso
muchas cosas al mismo tiempo
principalmente un espacio que nos
permita dialogar conversar conocernos a
nosotros mismos y entender a otros a
partir de la palabra poética hay tres
elementos que considero fundamentales y
que a su vez pueden mejorar las
interacciones sociales
el primero de estos elementos es la
oralidad la oralidad en la poesía de
acuerdo con nadie a lópez es eso la
poesía que se dice en voz alta
esta característica además de ser el
inicio de la palabra poética es también
su presente en un origen en un inicio la
poesía se comentaba de manera oral se
creaban textos de manera oral porque un
texto no necesariamente es un escrito
sino un texto como tejido de palabras y
de ideas entonces en la antigüedad
veíamos que las personas se reunían para
tener acceso al conocimiento que la
poesía en sí tiene porque la poesía no
sólo es una manera de percibir al mundo
ya la realidad sino también de
construirla
y estas mismas estructuras del pasado
las podemos ver todavía en el presente a
partir de los cantos poéticos las
lecturas en voz alta o los eventos open
mike seguimos reuniéndonos y
fortaleciendo nuestros vínculos sociales
a partir de la cuestión
el segundo de los elementos es el yo
poético
cuyo poético el yo poético no es jorge
cocom pech no es natalia toledo no es
briseida cuevas ni natalio hernández es
decir el yo poético no es el poeta no es
el escritor el yo poético es una voz que
habita que nos está contando el poema y
que permite que nos comuniquemos de
manera directa entre el escritor y el
lector y además permite que nos sintamos
a través del yo poético
esta característica nos permite
ejercitar de la manera más pura a la
empatía
porque cuando iniciamos a leer un poema
y empezamos a sentir lo que el poema
dice no le estamos preguntando el yo
poético que en donde trabaja cuánto gana
cuántas propiedades tienen y otras
preguntas que se le hacen a los seres
humanos para validar su existencia con
el yo poético libremente nos dejamos
sentir a partir de la confianza sabiendo
que así como nosotros el yo poético
también siente además de eso el yo
poético nos permite revertir y
reescribir la performatividad de acuerdo
con judith butler la performatividad es
la manera en la que llevamos a cabo las
ideas que no son impuestas la manera en
la que nos nombran por lo que se dice
sobre nosotros ella más bien lo acuña el
género pero también puede ser aterrizado
en el plan también planteamiento de la
identidad
entonces la poesía y el yo poético en
lugar de estar recibiendo estos mensajes
de que el motivo de nuestra existencia
es ser exitosos y que para ser exitosos
hay que acumular riquezas y dinero y que
para hacer eso se puede llevar a cabo un
proceso muy bien establecido pero que si
lo quieres hacer más rápido puedes
probar puedes ser corrupto o chantajear
en lugar de estar recibiendo
constantemente estos mensajes imagínense
leer
y leerse a partir de un yo poético que
se dice sensible que se dice humano que
se dice empático cambiaría la manera en
la que nos estamos percibiendo a
nosotros mismos y por tanto como
interactuamos con nuestro alrededor el
tercero de los elementos es la presencia
de figuras retóricas
a pesar de que el poema se caracteriza
por lo sensible no significa que esto es
lo único que habita el poema para
explicarlo patrick johansson alude a las
mil y una noches al cuento
específicamente de aladino él dice que
aladino se queda encerrado en una cueva
pero que a partir de una roca y de la
lámpara genera un roce y que cerró se
produce una chispa y que la chispa le
permite ver todo en la cueva
la roca y la lámpara dice patrick
johansson son el sentimiento y la razón
y cuando éstas producen fricción se
genera una chispa que ilumina aquello
que no estamos viendo
la chispa es la poesía
a esto podemos concatenar lo que ya
araceli mancilla nos decía en un inicio
y es que la poesía revela manifiesta
algo que no estamos viendo y a ello
puedo a su vez yo agregar que el la
presencia de las figuras retóricas
presentan ante nosotros un heimlich que
es un game league este conocimiento me
fue otorgado por luz a alvarado y ha
sido trabajado por heidegger por freud y
por muchos otros pensadores el en
heimlich es la revelación de algo que no
estamos viendo que por alguna razón no
percibimos de lo cotidiano el en
heimlich en la poesía es darse cuenta de
que así como yo me estoy sintiendo y
leyendo en este momento a partir de este
texto ya alguien se había sentido así
hace 500 hace 1000 o hace 3000 años cómo
es posible que con tanto tiempo de
distancia siga teniendo sentido
por las figuras retóricas de acuerdo con
moisés villaseñor auerbach genera una
teoría de huecos
huecos que son figuras retóricas y son
huecos porque el mensaje no está
completo nosotros a partir de nuestras
experiencias y de nuestra vida cotidiana
llenamos esos huecos y entonces el poema
tiene sentido la manera que permite esto
en la poesía es que no solo nos sepamos
y nos sintamos a través de un yo poético
sino que también podemos formar parte
del poema a través de las figuras
retóricas
qué puede hacer la poesía por nosotros y
por qué la necesitamos
la poesía no va a detener una bala que
está siendo disparada en contra de una
persona solo porque cruza fronteras que
existen ante la mente de algunos muy
pocos la poesía no va a cerrar las
puertas del transporte público de manera
intempestiva evitando que alguien robe
agrega viole la policía no le va a bajar
el volumen a la voz de una persona que
está atacando verbalmente a otra porque
esperar que la poesía haga eso por
nosotros es soslayar la responsabilidad
humana que hay en ello sin embargo y a
pesar de todo lo que he dicho fielmente
creo que muchas veces no actuamos
conforme a quienes realmente somos sino
a lo que se nos es impuesto a las ideas
a los estereotipos a los mensajes que
nos están constantemente transmitiendo
el sistema político el sistema económico
el de educación
muchas veces no estamos reflejando
quiénes somos en verdad pero como ya les
había dicho la poesía revierte esas
performatividad es y de hecho hay
evidencia juan gregorio regino
representante de la literatura mazateca
nos comparte que a partir de la poesía a
partir de escribirse y crearse por medio
de la poesía su pueblo logra darse
cuenta que no era lo que otros decían
que era se dio cuenta a partir de
escribirse libre
que era libre ese pueblo
la poesía a esas personas que están a
punto de disparar de atacar de violar de
agredir les recuerda que así como ellos
el que está enfrente también siente
también piensa es un eco de uno mismo a
estas personas que consideran que no
necesitamos a la poesía y que la poesía
no nos sirve para nada les contesto con
una frase de alfonso vargas la poesía
estaba condenada a existir y agregó yo
estaba condenada a existir porque la
necesitamos necesitamos a la poesía
porque nos recuerda que somos humanos
[Aplausos]